the race that goes through the center of
monaco starts on the busy albert the
first boulevard
german race car driver ellen law has
been living here for more than 20 years
and uses the boulevard daily
now and then i think here i am sitting
in the quiet neighborhood of la connamin
with a coffee
and a few years ago actually a bit
longer than that
50 meters from here i was holding the
trophy in my hands 50
the peaceful quarter of la condamine is
located right alongside albert the first
boulevard
next to the palace cliffs known as the
rock la condamine is the oldest part of
monaco
it's now been made into a pedestrian
zone
is located right next to the starting
line
it's dominated by old buildings and
apartments that don't have elevators
lokonomin is the opposite of hustle and
bustle
for me it's the most pleasant area here
there are plenty of nice shops far away
from the malls
you can shop and stroll too
man
we move on to the small church that
marks the spot where the start and
finish straightaways end
saint devote is where the course begins
winding its way up to the casino
monaco's most famous landmark
the place du casino glitters with a
glamour associated with the principality
international jet setting guests party
year-round at the hotel de paris
monaco native ari doria has been
watching the goings on here for 70 years
it might not be a symbol of monaco but
it's a pretty typical site here the
plastic casino is where ferraris meet
and greet
this is where luxury gathers it's been
that way for a decade
the casino was the start of monaco's
wealth
from the place to casino the racecourse
heads back downhill towards the fairmont
a luxury hotel built in the middle of a
cliff above the sea
the best view of the tightest curve in
the grand prix can be had from the roof
terraced pool
it's something that former silver arrow
driver sterling moss enjoys he and his
wife susie are regulars here of course
they stay in the suite named after him
images of his monaco victories decorate
the walls the suite has a balcony
overlooking the water
it's in the right place
got a fantastic view in they go past
and you know i think it's magic i mean
even even without bothering about the
grand prix it's sort of lovely you know
beautiful uh dining room and everything
oh i love it yeah i'm not sure how i
feel about you looking down from the
bedroom well i figured
i'm picking up hints
i followed fans here and they say you're
moting him
after the hairpin turns around the
fairmont hotel there's a straight
stretch through the tunnel
but of course that doesn't mean you can
drive fast here
it's too bad but you have to obey the
traffic laws
legendary paris dakar rally winner yota
kleinschmidt is always happy to get back
into the light at the end of the tunnel
that's when there's a view of monaco's
yacht harbor poor er cool
the ships that tie up here seem to get
bigger with each passing year
are plenty of restaurants down at
portside particularly in the west
opposite the raskas curve which brings
the grand prix drivers back to the main
straightaway
you miss a lot driving through here at
speed just like michael schumacher did
with his best time of one minute and 14
seconds
during the day you can have a coffee and
see more boats than you're likely to see
in many other places
and come evening it turns into a nice
promenade
in the bars and restaurants that line
the course the odds are pretty good at
any time of the year but you'll meet a
star race car driver because not
surprisingly many of them live in monaco